okay let's see where these fit in we'll
start with github
github is a service that lets users
interact with git there are a couple of
different ways that we could have
represented this
maybe github operates on git
or maybe even that github refers to git
but i chose to represent it as git being
a part of github
now let's think about remotes
a remote in your local repository
is basically a reference to another
repository
so we can say that remote refers to
repositories
also when you clone a repository a
remote gets set up for you automatically
so we could say that clone operates on
remotes so remote goes here
at this point the remaining two spots
are exactly the same
they both operate on both remote and
branch
so we could put these in either spot
let's check that this actually makes
sense when you push or pull you have to
specify what branch you want to push or
pull so it definitely operates on
branches
pull takes a branch from a remote
and brings it to your local repository
and push does the opposite taking a
branch and pushing it to a remote so
these do both operate on a remote as
well
all right we now have our concept map up
to this point